وقال الريس الصيني اذا انه يريد محادثات
صريحه مع بيدن بشان القضايا الاستراتيجيه
في العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه والمسائل
الاقليميه وكذلك الدوري
50 عاما مرت منذ بدايه العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين الصين والولايات المتحده
شهيدنا خلالها احداثا كثيره واكتسبنا
التجربه والخبرات وتعلمنا الدروس التاريخ
هو افضل كتاب نتعلم منه وعلينا ان ننظر
للتاريخ كي نرسم المستقبل
كرئيسين لدولتين عظيمتين علينا رسم المسار
الصحيح للعلاقات الثنائيه وتعزيز هذه
العلاقه اي رجل دوله يجب ان يعرف كيف يقود
بلده وكيف يتوافق مع الدول الاخرى والعالم
يتوقع العالم من الصين وامريكا ان تتعامل
بطريقه مناسبه وقد حظي اجتماعنا باهتمام
العالم في اجتماعنا اليوم انا جاهز ليكون
لدينا تبادل اراء صريح في ما يخص المسائل
المهمه استراتيجيا في العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه والمسائل الاقليميه والعالميه
لنعيد العلاقات الى مسارها الصحيح من اجل
خدمه البلدين والعالم